there is no good reason why we can't
train up enough truck drivers butchers
fruit Pickers Builders or welders
brexit enables us to build a
high-skilled high-wage economy that is
less dependent on low-skilled foreign
labor
that was our 2019 Manifesto pledge and
it's what we must deliver
so lucky to have with us Tori Grundy
conservative MP former Justice secretary
you make me feel about 100.
looking for the top job I suppose a lot
of people are suggesting this morning
well the top jobs filled by Rishi sunak
and I want him and most conservatives
want him to stay in post and to be our
prime minister winning a general
election and governing our country with
maturity and sense and a strong team
around him and Now's the Time for the
team to work with him to support him and
to project the five priorities that he
set out at the beginning of the year one
of which is beating inflation one of the
ways you beat inflation is by dealing
with those food prices that you're
talking about on the show today and
that's why I thought the remarks
yesterday the Home Secretary were
interesting we've got crops in the
fields now that need picking we've got
for example a pork a marketer Pig
farming Market that's been reduced by 20
what does that do to prices it rises
food prices we need to be doing
everything we can to Bear Down on
inflation and that includes supporting
our farming industry and allowing them
to get on with picking and rearing the
crops and products that they're famous
for
how should we interpret you saying her
remarks were interesting well look I
don't think it's any surprise that the
Home Secretary
wants to project a tough image on
immigration I think what is more
important is how realistic we can be so
let's take those figures on lawful
migration we include students uh in
those figures why do we do that most
students will leave this country after
they do their studies some might want to
stay and we need to make sure that
they're staying lawfully and they're not
bringing people in with them who
shouldn't be here I quite agree with
that but you know when we sort of have
this aggregate figure of migration I
think we un unnecessarily inflate the
figure we make it sound as if it's a a
big big threat to our country well in
fact some migration based upon a need
for skilled jobs that indeed other types
of jobs in the care industry for example
is absolutely essential if we're going
to continue to grow our economy
um some of your colleagues perhaps you
as well would say that after a rocky few
months Rishi sunak has steadied the ship
for the government for the conservative
party does
um the Home Secretary need to stay in
Helene well I think all departmental
ministers should stick to their brief
talk to their brief and support well of
course it is absolutely right and I'm
not criticizing the Home Secretary for
that but I think it's really important
that we project uh uh the correct
perception which should be the reality
that the Prime Minister uh came into uh
office in very difficult circumstances
last year he's as you say steady the
ship he's brought competence and
maturity to the job that I think is
extremely welcome and I think we owe it
to him and we did we owe it to the
conservative party which I've been a
member of for 35 years I'm I am older
than I look at that but you know I've
been a loyal conservative for 35 years I
believe in conservative values I believe
in uh whilst we uh allow our communities
and families to be at the core of
everything we do and we want to as lower
tax economy as possible uh you know we
can and should sometimes use the power
of the state in order to intervene and
make those necessary changes that's what
this government is doing in the best
traditions of conservative governments
and I think it deserves our support and
as we get to that election season it's
vital that we all cleave together
because the alternative believe you me
will be far worse okay so are we saying
that
um comments from swella bravaman and
others and and Breakaway conferences
down uh on the south coast at the
weekend are in danger of rocking the
boat well look I think the public uh
want to hear a very clear and consistent
message from the government they they
want to be reassured that doesn't have
to be happening if you read the paper
well I mean look I think on one level
having a lively policy debate shows that
we're not just talking about
personalities we're actually talking
about issues that will very often matter
to people out there which I think is a
healthy thing but at the same time I
think we all particularly ministers all
owe the government and oh that sense of
collective responsibility to be
disciplined uh to be very clear about
the priorities of the Prime Minister has
set out and to work towards what we
believe would be a conservative
government that would act in the
National interest that's we want the
next five years after the election to be
and I think everybody needs to bear that
in mind when entering the debate okay
you are a man of diplomacy as we know
often on the program are you just
telling her to shut up
look I'm saying to the Home Secretary
that she's got a big job to do I know
she wants to do it I think uh getting on
and doing that job is exactly where she
needs to be and you know the con the
conference of the conservative party
there are two competencies there's a
spring Forum which we just had and then
there's a conservative party conference
in the Autumn that's the platform uh
through which we should be projecting
our views and values yeah so she should
shut up is what you say well let's
concentrate on the job and and we have
as I say scheduled conferences which can
be used by senior members of the
government I'm going to take that as a
yes project there message oh got it I've
got it as far as the prime minister is
concerned heading to Iceland later on at
the rotating presidency of the council
for Europe what sort of reception do you
think he might get there well I think
he's going to get a good reception
because I think he's going there with
some substance and ideas about how for
example to reform one aspect of the
Court procedure this so-called rule 39
procedure that has caused some issue
with regard to the Rwanda
policy and to and to engage positively
with our colleagues in the Council of
you about guess what migration K because
I've been saying for ages Buy on about
this rages that the only way that we're
going to sort out these small boats and
illegal migration issue is for concerted
agreement at a European level so that
everybody is taking their fair share and
uh dealing with this what is an
international crisis rather than
something just can just be done here at
home yeah we don't have enough people to
do the jobs do we I mean you would yeah
we're going full circle and that surely
means that we should be looking at
allowing some Europeans who used to come
previously to be able to come into the
United Kingdom in order to do those jobs
that it would appear that British people
don't want to do yeah and look I want
more British people to work I'm working
on particular issues relating to
economic inactivity to help the
government but you're right about lawful
migration where there's an identified
need you know it's care workers
agricultural workers other types of
skilled employment then we should be
allowing people to come here and that's
why those numbers have risen because
that's what we're doing now that's a
sign I think of a growing economy the
issue with regard to getting more
British residents to work is frankly one
that will take longer and we have to be
realistic that in the meantime some
measure of controlled lawful migration
will be necessary what I think the prime
minister is doing today well I think you
know for example where where there's a
shortage in agriculture then bring
people in in order to do that so
seasonal work in on a Visa system and
expand that well if necessary yes and I
think the prime minister's right today
to talk to other European countries uh
mainly about the small boat's unlawful
issue which of course is a byproduct of
refugee issues coming for if refugees
coming from other parts of the world the
only way you're going to do that okay is
internationally and that's why I'm
really pleased he's going to Reykjavik
today just let me ask you briefly
slightly off topic if you would please
um we're being told that KIA St Arma is
considering changing the rules if he
wins the next election
to allow Europeans who now live in the
United Kingdom pay the taxes here in the
United Kingdom and 16 and 17 year olds
to be able to vote incoming elections
how do you feel about that I think that
any major constitutional change whether
it's reform to the electoral system or
indeed increasing the franchise quite
substantially should be made subject to
a referendum by the British people we
should be deciding major constitutional
reform issues I don't think governments
of whatever parties should be able to
just get elected into office and then
change the rules uh they only change the
rules I think in particular labor early
change the rules because they think it's
going to help them I think the rest of
it secret Victoria's do that too well I
mean folks who are ID everybody said
some somehow it was some gimmick to help
the Tories I don't think the recent
election results showed that K I think
any constitutional change of that nature
should be subject to all of our consent
or disagreement by way of a referendum
and I think we should legislate to
create a referendum lock to make sure
that constitutional changes do not
happen without our consent so Robert
always a pleasure thank you very much
India for joining us thank you